let me ask you just uh
for uh as somebody who's seen the whole
thing the the development of the
millions of Articles uh
big impossible question uh what's your
favorite article my favorite article
well I've got a uh an amusing answer
um which is possibly also true
um there's uh an article in Wikipedia
called inherently funny words
and one of the reasons I love it is
when it was created early in in the
history of Wikipedia it kind of became
like a Dumping Ground people would just
come by and write in any word that they
thought sounded funny and then it was
nominated for deletion because
somebody's like this is just a dumping
around like people are putting all kinds
of nonsense in
and in that deletion debate somebody
came forward and said essentially wait a
second hold on this is actually a
legitimate Concept in the theory of
humor and comedy and a lot of famous
comedians and humorous have written
about it and
it's you know it's actually a legitimate
topic so then they went through and they
meticulously referenced every word that
was in there and threw out a bunch that
weren't and so it becomes this really
interesting now my biggest
disappointment and it's the right
decision to make
um because there was no Source but
it was a picture of a cow
but there was a rope around its head
tying on some horns onto the cow so it
was kind of a funny looking picture it
looked like you know like a bull you
know with horns but it's just like a
normal milk cow and below it the caption
said according to some cow is an
inherently funny word which is just
hilarious to me partly because the
according to Psalm sounds a lot like
Wikipedia but there was no source so it
went away and I I feel very sad about
that but I've always liked that and I
actually the reason depths of Wikipedia
amuses me so greatly is because it does
like highlight really interesting
obscure stuff and you're like wow I
can't believe somebody wrote about that
in Wikipedia it's quite amusing and
sometimes there's a bit of raw humor in
Wikipedia there's always a struggle
you're not trying to be funny but
occasionally a little inside humor can
be quite healthy in apparently words
with the letter k are fun there's a lot
of really well researched stuff on this
page
it's actually exciting and I should
mention for dubs to Wikipedia uh it's
run by
any rewarda that's right Annie and uh
let me just read off some of the pages
uh uh octopolis and octalantis oh yeah
that was our two separate non-human
underwater settlements built by the
gloomy octopuses in Jervis Bay east
Australia the first settlement named
octopolis by biologist was founded in
2009 the individual structures in
octopus consist of burrows around a
piece of human uh to treat us believed
to be scrap metal and it goes on in this
way
um
right uh satiric misspelling least
concerned species humans were formally
assessed as a species of least concern
in
in in 2008 uh I think uh Hitchhiker's
Guide to the Galaxy uh would slightly
disagree and last one let me just say
friendship Paradox is the phenomena
first observed by the sociologist Scott
felt in 1991 that on average an
individual's friends have more friends
than that individual oh that's
experience
that's the kind of thing that makes you
wanna
like it sounds implausible at first
because shouldn't everybody have on
average about the same number of friends
as all their friends so you really want
to dig into the math of that and really
think oh why would that be true and uh
it's one way to feel more lonely in a
mathematically rigorous way